un bon soir paul antoine merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous sur rt france est-ce
que selon vous ces accusations contre
hashim thaçi sont fondées et je suis
évidemment qu'elle se reformer la
plupart des services de renseignements
occidentaux qui ont travaillé avec
hashim thaçi ils ont travaillé avec lui
dans leurs rapports disent que mathieu
thaçi était l'un des principal
responsable de la mafia albanaise et du
terrorisme albanais au kosovo dans les
années 2000 l'ofce cas d'ailleurs étant
plus qu'une armée de libération c'était
une organisation terroriste
reconnue comme terroriste par l'otan est
mis sur la liste des organisations
terroristes de l'otan avant 99 y avant
le bombardement illégale de la
yougoslavie par l'otan donc évidemment
monsieur thaçi est un criminel de guerre
il a commis des crimes de guerre il a
commis des crimes contre l'humanité je
rappelle quand même que c'est son
deuxième procès le premier procès sur
douze témoins qui étaient tous albanais
6 qui les douze témoins d'ailleurs
étaient sous la protection de la police
de l'europe le luxe au kosovo six ont
été assassinés évidemment les six autres
qui tiennent à la vie ont décidé de ne
plus trop témoigner évidemment messieurs
thaçi et les autres personnes passent il
n'y a pas que monsieur thaçi il ya il y
a plusieurs autres dirigeants des
membres de logica qui sont attendus à la
ils sont évidemment coupable et j'espère
qu'ils seront condamnés pour crimes de
guerre et crimes contre l'humanité
alors il ya ce jeu c'est un peu la liste
de ce qui lui est reproché meurtre d'une
centaine de personnes tortures
persécutions disparitions forcées et
j'en passe ça concerne aussi des faits
qui se seraient alors le tribunal
spécial de la haye ne va pas juger de ce
qui s'est passé après la guerre mais ça
aurait continué aussi puisqu'elle il ya
eu 500 disparition de ses opposants
politiques par exemple la liste est
longue
les témoins risquent de ne pas se
présenter comme c'était le cas jusqu'à
présent
la liste est malheureusement trop longue
vous savez je vais répondre à votre
question évidemment mais je pense qu'il
la question est un petit peu ailleurs si
vous me permettez monsieur datchy
monsieur haradinaj tout l'exécutif de ce
faux état du kosovo sont évidemment des
clowns elle de guerre pour moi la
question n'est pas là tout le monde le
sait tout le monde le sait pour moi la
vraie question si vous voulez on parle
de guerre je considère que la guerre est
un crime
pour moi il faut toucher à ceux qui ont
donné des armes
il faut toucher à ceux qui ont permis à
monsieur thaçi de commerce et crimes de
guerre
qui sont ils je pense que sur le banc
des accusés à côté de monsieur thaçi ou
en tout cas dans les discussions pas
dans le sur le banc des accusés excusez
moi sur les dents les discussions il
serait bien d'entendre monsieur bernard
henri lévy il serait bien d'entendre
monsieur kouchner ministre est bien
tentant de monsieur bernard acoyer qui
était président de l'assemblée nationale
qui a reçu il ya coupe krasniqi jakup
krasniqi est lui aussi entendu pour
crimes de guerre et crimes contre
l'humanité
je pense qu'il faudrait entendre
monsieur domjan je ne dis pas que c'est
jean son coupable de quoi que ce soit je
pense qu'il faudrait les entendre
monsieur danjean qui est aujourd'hui
député les républicains au parlement
européen je pense qu'il faut que la
france qui a tenu un rôle dans cette
guerre au kosovo lance une enquête
parlementaire sur le rôle de certains
hommes politiques sur ce qui s'est passé
au kosovo et notamment sur monsieur tati
vous rappellerai les crimes les crimes
étaient commis des deux côtés paul
antoine
d'ailleurs les deux côtés sont jouant
évidemment la grande différence voulais
c'est que les serbes eux ont donné leurs
criminels c'est eux qui les ont donnés
ils ont donné il ya dix ans le général
lazarevic qui était le chef d'état major
de l'armée serbe au kosovo a déjà purgé
sa peine il y a plusieurs années il a
fait dix ans de prison
je vous rappelle que le général de le
chef d'état major de l'armée bosno
serbes le général ratko mladic a été
donnée par le président serbe boris
tadic
les serbes ont décidé de donner tout
leur criminels de guerre les albanais
n'ont jamais voulu faire ça je vous
rappellerai quand même que les albanais
responsables de crimes de guerre ont été
mis à la haye depuis que trump et
président parce qu'abidal est un grand
ami de monsieur thaçi si vous voulez le
procès de monsieur thaçi va beaucoup
plus loin que la question du kosovo
il voit dans les ramifications en france
en allemagne en autriche et évidemment
aux états unis s'y est donc comment vous
voyez les l'issue de ce procès qui
risque de durer quelques quelques mois
voire quelques années
ben c'est simple soit malheureusement
comme ça a déjà été le cas les victimes
que ce soit des victimes sert gorani ou
albanaise vont se faire je dirais voler
le procès comme ça a déjà une pile
malheureusement le cas une fois où on va
avoir une farce de procès le le la est
malheureusement il est connu pour ça
c'est pas la plus grande justice qu'on
ait connu donc il y as soit 5 soit on va
avoir une vraie justice et monsieur
patxi va être condamné
encore une fois moi je pense que ils
dorment c'est thaçi doit être condamné
mais les gens qui l'ont soutenu en
france en allemagne en angleterre et aux
états unis eux aussi devraient être
condamnés c'est ça qui pour moi est le
plus important
merci beaucoup paul antoine d'avoir
répondu ce soir à nos questions sur arte
france